- Here we are.
We are about to release a
Season Five of Worth It.
We've done four seasons.
(growling noise)
That sounds like Chewbacca.
(beep)
You guys ask a lot of questions.
- We never give any answers.
(laughs)
So, we're finally doing a Q & A video.
- Why not take some time to answer some
of your most burning
questions about Worth It.
The behind the scenes, behind
the curtain, the secrets.
- We thought that we would eat something
while we did it.
We're making peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches.
The jam from Squirrel Cafe.
- Jammin' the squirrel.
- And this is bread from Republique,
from the spaghetti episode.
Mmm.
- I took the first bite.
I was scared I couldn't bite it off,
so I just aborted mission
and threw it all in my mouth.
We had a Worth It Instagram account,
it's buzzfeedworthit.
And we're gonna now answer some
of the most popular
questions on Instagram.
Question number one:
"How did you guys meet?"
- There was an unscripted-ish department
at the time that you worked on,
and somebody on that team was looking
for a new, unscripted food show.
And you were tasked
with coming up with this
on-the-road, food, travel-ish show,
like, city-guide show.
I was added to that show to help reduce,
and like be a character on that.
(beep)
This sauce is incredible.
- It's whimsical.
- Whimsical.
- "Is a hot dog a sandwich?
And what are your thoughts
on pineapple pizza?"
- Is a hot dog a sandwich?
- Yes.
On three.
One, two, three.
- No.
- Hey.
Is a hot dog a sandwich?
- Adam says no.
- And what are your
thoughts on pineapple pizza?
- Pro or negative on three.
One, two, three.
- Pro.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- @juliadural, "How do you
say Andrew's last name?"
- So my last name looks hard to pronounce,
but is actually very easy to pronounce.
It's Il-nik-ee.
- "What was the most fun
Worth It video to film?"
- Ooh.
You know what was really fun,
is when we went to Seattle
to eat some salmon.
'Cause we were just like
on a jolly road adventure.
It was like a fun, new place.
I was blown away by the autumnal glory
of the Pacific Northwest.
- I would have to say sushi.
Not part one, though.
- Hmm.
- Teaser alert.
That's all I'm gonna say about that.
- Not really a great food to talk through.
- "Who else is on your team?
I don't think you guys are mean enough
to stick Adam with all the work."
Great question, I'm glad you asked,
because over the years,
we have had so many people who have
contributed to the show in so many ways,
that's just made Worth
It what it is today.
- As you know, we make
this show here at Buzzfeed,
where there's a ton of great people
that help and support
us make what we make.
Like there's a research team,
that makes sure that we're factual.
There's a legal team,
that makes sure that
everything we do is legal,
at least what you see on camera, hey-o.
There's a production team,
that helps with scheduling
and getting us places on time.
A whole post-production support team.
This season we have an extra
special additional person,
who's name is Annie.
You're gonna see her in
a bunch of the videos.
(laughs)
So if you ever hear that
trademark laugh in the background,
you know who it's coming from.
- You know.
- "What is the craziest
thing that happened
off-camera that we haven't seen?"
There's been some moments.
- Yeah, there's one time (beep).
And that is probably the worst thing
that's happened on set.
- "What happened to
the 1000 cinnamon rolls
you owed Adam Bianchi on
the fried chicken episode?"
- That wasn't our fried
chicken episode, that was a--
- Game day foods, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, you owe Adam
1,000 cinnamon rolls.
- I do.
- Or one thousand dollar cinnamon roll.
(beep)
- Adam, if you finish that,
I'll buy you a thousand
cinnamon rolls, if you eat that.
I'm going to not give
him all 1,000 at once.
I'm gonna kill him slowly.
One at a time.
So it's starting today.
- So how many have you given him?
- Number one.
This is me starting my
quest to pay off my debt.
- That's one down.
Put the ticker on the screen.
We've eaten like ten dollars
worth of jam already.
- "How does Andrew feel getting killed off
by Ryan and Shane?"
- (sighs) I feel fine about it.
I mean, when they killed me,
they dropped me in a pool.
(Titanic flute music)
- Insult.
- Oh.
- Did he just die?
- They'll get theirs.
- "What is one food you would
never do an episode for?"
by Abby Regs.
- I mean, there's lots of
answers to this question,
because the food just doesn't make sense
at different price points.
- Mm-hmm.
Adam said spiders, I'd have to agree.
Probably, crickets.
- I'd probably say
peanut butter and jelly.
- "How is Adam doing?
And "Does he get enough food?"
- Adam, do you want to
answer for yourselr?
Or do you want me to take this one?
- You wanna answer how he's doing?
- Well, I'm not gonna answer that,
but Adam is currently eating
a peanut butter and jelly.
(laughs)
- How are you doing?
- He just went like this.
- And now the final question,
"Have you ever disliked the food
or any part of the experience
from places that you've eaten at?"
- We go to three restaurants
that are already worth it.
We're really just trying
to find the best food,
at three price points, and so
there really hasn't been
anything that's just like,
not delivered in it's given price tier.
- I've definitely
enjoyed every experience.
It was worth trying the two
thousand gold pizza, to me,
because I got to see what that was like.
This is fun.
We could do it again.
- We're gonna have to get
some more jam, though.
Pan over there.
- Very special news, we have merch.
- Sick merch, heading your way.
- It's available now.
(magical chimes)
- We'll see you next week,
on Season five, six episodes.
You wanna reveal next week's episode?
- Hinty teaser, it's not gonna be small,
and it's not gonna be a vegetable.
- Medium fish.
- Guess again.
(laughs)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now you're part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.